what's been your most memorable day of
shooting so far in series 3 we had a big
big fight scene with a flaming sword and
that took that took three days to or two
and a half days and it was great we had
a lot of fun but it was really hard as
well there was a big roaring fire going
and I'm the week before we'd been
exterior the whole week and it'd been
raining and we're like how it's get into
the paint hole got into the paint
Horner's absolutely boiling and we were
like you know I'd much rather be outside
it was it was so hot and they had to
fight as well and had all that big armor
on as well and it kind of it just you
know but we did have a lot of fun but it
was just really trying day and very
memorable and just true impressive as
well it's kind of like a fight scene
that I'm not actually fighting I was
just sort of watching which was cool and
I'm yeah it was great and it looks
fantastic too and I just remember being
like and it's so hot as well like the
sword comes past you know it's like you
know it would be so difficult to fight
with a flaming sword I think but it was
actually flaming as well which is cool
that they didn't CG that it was it was
genuine not Jordan genuinely on fire so
that was cool to kind of actually see
that that's incredible definitely with
any other moments that you think oh well
you know if fans knew the behind the
scenes of Game of Thrones what would
they find surprising do you think the
beheading I think for a lot of it it was
just guy really slowly raising a sword
and then lowering a sort and then going
cut and that was kind of it for a lot of
it then they came closer and did I tell
you even know how they did it it was
kind of fake head not fake head Shan
fake body had blood done it was yeah
it's kind of strange and I think people
it wasn't like his I was kind of because
this is gonna be amazing and then and
then it was just like oh we'll put the
fake head in now okay we'll take that
out and we'll put blood here and okay
we're done I was like ah ok I thought
someone was gonna actually the head cut
off or something really cool you know so
we're gonna have like blood wait we just
yeah
I think people be like oh that was you
know that was not why I expected at all
I know what you do when you kind of
because you have a lot of emotional
scenes as I don't you can go to some
quite dark places how do you chill out
how do you shake all that off at the end
of a shoot um sometimes if it's a really
emotional scene it's kind of hard to get
back sometimes and they call cart and
you're a bit like because you've just
really made yourself upset and I'm I
think just to chill out really a go back
to the hotel and either have room
service you can just sit in your bed
with your pajamas on or in between takes
and stuff I just make jokes with the
other casts and people come around and
cheer you up and you know usually when
it's really intense so just say
something and everyone will laugh no but
I have okay you know bring it back up
again because everyone's kind of silent
and so that was a bit sad someone brings
it back up again which is nice so yeah
and sometimes it's hard to go from like
a really upbeat scene to a really sad
scene because you're still like and
they're like okay right we're gonna go
on to this you're like I'm not quite
there yet and not quite ready and so
yeah it's kind of a bit up and down on
set but I really enjoy it is it's kind
of different to anything else I've ever
done what obviously but um yeah it's
it's a mad world really you mentioned
jokes Thorin so he's the biggest
prankster he's the biggest Joker on
sense Ben hawky he constantly imitates
other people and it's not just their
accent it's like a complete impression
of someone and their mannerisms and
everything and he's like see that guy
over there and then just starts doing it
and I'm like how do you even do that
it's it's mad and um does impressions of
people and you know before we rolled as
someone who you know everyone's saying
quiet please no no and there's like
little repetition of things that people
call out and Ben's just there in the
corner saying the same things and like
Ben stop it we're supposed to be going
and I'm supposed to be angry with you
and you're making me laugh and that
scene in Episode one where we're both
walking through the woods all three of
us are walking through the woods it was
just chuckling when it's on a wide shot
he's just you know constantly making
jokes and things and Joe also kind of
you know eggs Amman which
he's really hard they're like an action
and I'm like oh my god I can't stop
laughing and take this seriously and I'm
like pull it's get amazing but yeah it's
great fun you mentioned obviously been
hockey plays hot pie what was his wolf
bred like every dry they made loads of
double servic there was like 60 wolf
bred things on this table just like and
they had a couple of different editions
of it so you know and they wanted to
pick the one look the most ridiculous
and for that one's hilarious especially
because she's like oh yeah that's the
tail and it was like massive this big
clump on the end of the breads yeah that
was perfect but yeah it was kind of
they've got to make it look like you've
got to make it look good even if it
doesn't taste great because you know
people aren't going to taste it from
from there so for at home so they got
make it look good and then sometimes
it's like yeah we didn't have taste
division for that yeah how many times do
you have to do that I think only about
four or five times yeah and the
beginning you know I always get excited
when there's a tasting scene because I
really love food I'm like have it the
first time I'm like yeah it was really
overrated no I'm not crazy about this
Wilfred like you kind of have it in your
mouth at the end of the taking
everyone's like you okay and like like
Oh we'll get your tissue I'm like now
maybe what's it meant to you to be part
of Game of Thrones I think when it all
started it didn't expected to get as big
as it has and you know I now really feel
a part of it and I was there since the
pilot episode that we filmed and you
know it's it's slowly got bigger and
bigger and bigger I've always wanted to
perform and I finally got my foot in the
door and I'm excited to see what the
future holds
that sounds really cheesy but I am more
excited for you and we're so glad you
got the foot in the door I'm sure it'll
be wide wide open in the future what
would you like to say to the fans out
there who watch this into you Maisie um
thanks for watching it's kind of nice to
show Maisie as well sometimes because
everyone's used to see me playing Arya
it's nice to just you know show you what
I'm like and yeah I'm not quite
grumpy Azaria quite you know
light-hearted but yeah thanks for
watching the show and it wouldn't be
quite the way it is without you guys so
yeah thanks for that amazing it's been
an absolute pleasure to meet you we've
enjoyed meeting Maisie Williams behind
that is doc thank you thank you very
much
you